When performing a t-test, we assume that our data
is normal. In the wild, you'll often encounter probability distributions.
They're distinctly not normal. They might look like this, or
like this, or completely different. As you'd imagine, there are
still statistical tests that we can utilize when our data
is not normal. Why don't we briefly discuss what you
might do in situations like this. First off, we should
have some machinery in place for determining whether or not
our data is Gaussian in the first place. A crude, inaccurate
way of determining whether or not our data is normal is
simply to plot a histogram of our data and ask, does
this look like a bell curve? In both of these cases, the
answer would definitely be no. But, we can do a little
bit better than that. There are some statistical tests that we
can use to measure the likelihood that a sample is drawn
from a normally distributed population. One such test is the shapiro-wilk test.
I don't want to go into great depth with
regards to the theory behind this test, but I do
want to let you know that it's implemented in scipy.
You can call it really easily like this. W and
P are going to be equal to scipy.stats.shapiro data, where
our data here is just an array, or list containing
all of our data points. This function's going to return these
two values. The first, W is the Shapiro-Wilk Test statistic.
The second value in this two-pole is going
to be our P value, which should be interpreted
in the same way that we would interpret
the p-value for our t-test. That is, given the
null hypothesis that this data is drawn from
a normal distribution, what is the likelihood that we
would observe a value of W that was at least as extreme as the one that we see?